Yanis missed that shot as the pass goes
off be honest his hands Jana started
rapping indeed at midcourt cause he knew
when he was going to post him up right
away he was trying to keep them from
doing a description Sandrine's at three
and it's nine five Billy two minutes in
Al Horford now working on Matthews is a
really tenacious defender impede
hovering on the perimeter a lot he
switches home at three there to tie it
up at 14 through the first here in
Philly on Christmas Day
Harris got a good look and drains it
that's a third three for Philadelphia
well playing through the low post you're
speeding it up the floor and it results
in this kind of opportunity or fer to
step back three this go Wow Trey Burke
left alone and access the cut three for
Philly on 11 tries looking ahead we're
not doing that this year a block by
Connaughton three on the shot clock
MB pass to pull the trigger
that smokes the net and remember this is
why Shaquille O'Neal and Charles Barkley
believe this guy's a monster talents
wanted more consistently Richard saying
that seven threes on the staff of
Philly's four goals have been from
behind the arc and again that's normally
not their game well we can take a seat
now
[Music]
Richardson straight good again 11-point
Philly leads
Tobias Harris to the first half let's
come from JoEllen beef to buy his Harris
made two three give him something cheer
about
marine averaging 32 per game Oscar was
32 years old then Bobby Dandridge
look how long that's been so again you
see the retreat to the paint by Robin
Lopez so here comes Joelle just gonna
walk up into a very comfortable three
you see the hesitation pathetic gumbo
driving and he missed again he's four
for 14 to your point on Simmons getting
ahead quickly Richardson gets up at 67
first half points for filling the only
six free throw tries on the 90 well so
as you mentioned under Mike Budenholzer
he added this dimension to his condition
zone Kawhi Leonard and Paul George
almost at the midway point of the year
they have shown science of what they
will be as against the zone port Maas
gets to an open area the largest deficit
not just this year but the last genius
Wow regular-season game Kentucky but
there's Harris again that is 14
[Music]
[Applause]
well the only guy that really hasn't
stepped back and shot a three is cork
box hits again shooting in the mid-30s
from behind the arc birds on his watch
court bonds again the East gonna be
pretty entertaining compliant I'm like
Scott 17 for the Sixers shot clock at
five years Korkmaz
that's the 18th rate for filling a
season-high and Korkmaz has four of them
all the next couple minutes go has been
Simmons kicking it out to Tobias Harris
and he got it to him in a great spot and
Harris drilled it shot clock down to two
Harris puts it off
and straight game efficient use of the
Tribble as this shot clock is winding
down and you seen it going and the great
challenge by deep ingento the one thing
you'd say is Horford Decker
[Applause]